Last week I had two sacks and an interception,
and this week I had a pass defense, but I hurt
my groin. Coach says to stay out because
I'm really important.
Oh, Teej, I gotta run, your brother's here.
Ya know, he's raised 37 million dollars?
He's a G-D angel!
I get it - Mom. I'll never be as good as J.J.
Well, that's your first problem. Trynna be good.
Start trynna be bad. We're the Steelers,
and we're nasty.
Nasty, OK. Like Big Ben, or?
No no no no no. Not like that.
That's nice, kid. After this we're gonna buy you
some nasty-ass sweatpants and shoot videos
of us doing 700-pound pelvic thrusts.
T.J.! What's going on here?
Get outta here, J.J.! I'm a Nasty Steeler Boy now.
You're a Watt, and Watts do not upset Goodell.
So sorry I'm not perfect, J.J.! Maybe because
around you I feel like the forgotten Watt.
Well now hold on.
Who the hell are you?
I'm Derek Watt, and I play fullback on the
Chargers in Los Angeles.
So check your Watt privilege.
I'm so sorry.